so franchises cost 250 000 to start up
in legal fees and they're basically
government sanctioned business
opportunities I get so many guys who are
like I like to franchise someday most
times the businesses suck you don't have
a business that people would want to buy
into you're the 29th different boot
camps there's no competitive mode
there's no Advantage it's very difficult
to sell a business opportunity that
makes less than a million bucks Top Line
usually at least 250 000 bottom line
McDonald's averages 150 000 it's like
yeah but McDonald's has already 60 years
on you they have this massive brand and
when you open up you already have all
this brand recognition the advantage of
having a franchisor buying into a
franchise is that the risk of franchises
failing compared to businesses on their
own is significantly lower if you have a
business that requires tons of capital
and has lots of operational complexity
to open then it's something that may
lend itself well to a franchise because
you decentralize the effort and the
capital